bonsoir robert merci pour votre accueil
moi je vais vous parler de vélo ce soit
à j'ai envie de vous poser une question
qui dans la salle se souvient de sa
dernière expérience à vélo
ah et pour qui c'était une expérience
agréable
mais c'est super
alors moi j'adore cette expérience le
vélo et c'est pas un hasard parce que en
fait moi j'ai grandi là paradis du vélo
les pays-bas et si j'ai envie ce soir de
vous parler de ce paradis du vélo c'est
que moi je crois que le vélo est une
extraordinaire écoles de liberté et
d'autonomie surtout pour les enfants
voilà aux pays-bas les enfants trois
enfants sur quatre vont à l'école tout
seul à vélo et rapport des nations-unies
dit que les enfants nir landais sont les
enfants les plus heureux du monde alors
pourquoi c'est entre autres parce qu'ils
ont cette liberté des déplacements ils
sont pas dépendants d'un parent derrière
le volant deux chauffeurs de bus
derrière le volant ni d'un itinéraire
debussy peuvent aller comme ils veulent
c'est une source de liberté et donc de
bonheur
alors un enfant qui prend le guidon son
vélo en fait il prend le guidon de sa
vie il apprend que c'est lui qui décide
où il va s'il va à gauche ci va à droite
en fait il apprend que si les décideurs
y devient entrepreneur
pionnier aventurier il prend goût à la
vie il prend il apprend à oséo 6
et même les tout-petits aux pays bas qui
ne peuvent pas encore un pédaler comme
par exemple dans ce bac du vélo cargo de
leurs parents ils apprennent déjà ils
apprennent le vans la lumière du soleil
qui change le bruit des voitures qui
s'approche qui ce qui s'éloigne la
géographie du quartier la ville alors
est-ce que vous pensez que on pourrait
offrir cette liberté et cette bonne ce
bonheur à nos enfants en france et même
à nous mêmes moi je pense que si et je
vais vous le montrer
est ce que vous connaissez cette rue
c'est la rue de rivoli c'est la rue
c'est le prolongement des champs-elysées
et c'est un truc est connu pour être
désagréable en voiture et aussi à vélo
et voici
voilà
la même rue deux ans plus tard alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre ces deux
moments est ce que il y aura eu une
sorte de révolution culturelle entre ces
deux moments pendant deux ans non pas du
tout moi je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de la révolution du vélo en
ile de france
pour moi le déclic et aides en 2016 donc
hollande est en france je me sentais un
peu seul sur mon vélo et j'ai pris une
décision qui a transformé ma vie j'ai
créé un groupe de travail pour rendre ma
ville cyclable c'est à dire pour en
faire une ville où on a le choix de se
déplacer partout en sécurité nous
l'avons appelé fontenay aux roses à vélo
phare à vélo
et la force d'un groupe c'est bien sûr
voilà les sourires l'énergie la
solidarité mais c'est surtout ce désir
que vous avez un commun d'obtenir
quelque chose ensemble et pour nous
c'était donc la société cyclable alors
comment créer société cyclable alors on
s'est dit il faut qu'on s'organise il
faut pas qu'on se mettre sur les canapés
qu'on attende que les politiques nous
servent la société cyclables et donc on
a pris une sale on a invité toutes les
associations vélo de la banlieue sud de
paris à fontenay-aux-roses dans cette
salle vous voyez les responsables de 18
associations qui représente 4000
adhérents et on a discuté comment faire
et en fait il se trouve qu'à ce moment
même le département nous sommes le 92
les hauts-de-seine projetés ça pour
réaménager l'ancienne nationale 20
grosses artères qui entrent dans paris
sans prévoir de l'espace dédié pour le
vélo les vélos étaient quand vous le
voyez obligé de se dépatouiller avec les
voitures et nous on ne vit pas on ne
peut pas accepter ça et donc on a rédigé
une contre proposition qu'on a envoyé au
département et devinez quoi le
département a voulu discuter avec nous
de notre proposition à pau parce que
pendant des années on n'y arrivait pas
vous savez pourquoi ils nous ont
expliqué que notre proposition était
d'une grande qualité c'est pas un hasard
parce que si vous êtes un grand groupe
de personnes il ya forcément des experts
mais il ya une autre raison c'est que
nous étions nombreux et organisés comme
ici ce soir dans la salle nous étions
devenus importants pour eux et ça ça
nous a galvanisés
on s'est dit il faut qu'on fasse ça pour
toute la région ile de france on va
rassembler toutes les associations vélo
de l'île de france et on va transformer
notre région première région de france
12 millions d'habitants première
économie de france voilà ça va ça va
cartonner
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait nous avons
créé le collectif vélos y de france
aujourd'hui plus de 40 associations 7000
adhérents et nous existons
alors ce qui se passe c'est que quand
vous rassembler autant de personnes dans
une pièce comme ici par exemple vous
accédez à ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence collective
vous voyez plus clair vous réfléchissez
plus vite c'est très très enivrant nous
par exemple on se rendait compte que
pendant des années nous ont pensé que
toutes ces associations vélo qu'une
autre problème c'était voilà telle ou
telle piste cyclable qui ne fonctionnait
pas weed man iman canard sur vélo là en
fait non le vrai problème c'était qu'il
manque un réseau cyclable en ile de
france
voici le réseau cyclable dit de france
c'est de confettis voilà ça ne marche
pas si vous faites ça pour un train le
train il ne va pas rouler et donc on
s'est dit on va créer ce réseau cyclable
est donc un dimanche matin on s'est
rendu chez notre ami françois-xavier
monaco 1 malakoff on a pris une grande
carte de la région la mise sur la table
on a pris les feutres et on a commencé à
dessiner les neuf pistes cyclables du
futur réseau cyclable de france histoire
extraordinaire
et voici le résultat neuf mois plus tard
n'appliquez beaucoup de monde à gauche
vous voyez le rer tout le monde connaît
les revers chez le réseau des trains
d'ile-de-france et à droite vous voyez
notre proposition du réseau cyclable et
quand vous pouvez le constater notre
proposition était une copie du réseau
des trains en fait on a fait exprès pour
que les gens le reconnaissent
instinctivement comme un réseau de
transport et pas juste comme la bile là
la piste cyclable pour la balade du
dimanche après-midi et ja fonctionner
parce que alors qu'on était encore en
train de décider en juin 2019
la patronne de la région valérie
pécresse intuit ça m'intéresse votre
réseau cyclable qu'on avait d'ailleurs
baptisé hervé rer vélo pour que
justement les gens me reconnaissent
comme un réseau elle a dit je veux
discuter avec vous mais on n'a pas pu
aller plus loin tout de suite parce que
la copie de t'arriver pas de bombe
catastrophe toutes les autorités
politiques avaient d'urgence besoin
d'une solution de transport avec plus de
distanciation physique que les
transports en commun ou on a un peu trop
comme ça et voilà le virus circule trop
et avec un peu moins de distanciation
physique les voitures parce que si tout
le monde prenait la voiture au
déconfinement on serait congestionné les
villes et le vélo m'a c'est juste au
milieu voilà ça donne juste cette bulle
dont on a besoin pour être protégé
alors qu' à 7 à ce moment de mon
histoire qui raconte donc la révolution
du vélo en ile de france inquiète donc
une histoire de citoyens qui tu es juste
nombreux organisée et qui avait un
projet qui a maintenant envie de
transformer son territoire sa ville en
ville cyclable
yes alors je propose de parler de la
société cyclable comme vous le voyez
c'est une photo de thomas schreiber un
photographe qui a photographié la
société cyclables aux pays bas moi je
pense une bonne nouvelle pour vous que
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour vous
d'en parler que pour moi parce que moi
en tant qu aux landais quand je parle du
vélo quand je dis le vélo c'est bien
vous savez ce qu'on me répondre mais
steyn c'est normal vous êtes hollandais
vous avez ça dans votre culture et votre
pays a depuis toujours été cyclables
c'est faux voici les pays-bas dans les
années 70 les routes étaient tellement
plein de voitures que les enfants ne
pouvaient pas jouer dans la rue on ne
pouvait très difficilement faire du vélo
est d'ailleurs le néerlandais il on
avait même ras-le-bol
regardez bien ces deux photos à gauche
l'ambiance à la hollandaise avec des
belles pistes cyclables et à droite
l'ambiance à la française où les vélos
doivent un peu slalomer entre les
voitures
détrompez vous ces deux photos ont été
prises exactement au même endroit dans
la rue st jakob à utrecht mais avec 45
ans d'écart qu'est ce qui s'est passé
entre ces deux moments est ce que ce
sera une révolution culturelle
non pas du tout moi je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de la révolution du
vélo aux pays bas
malheureusement cette histoire commence
par un drame
un jour il ya une petite fille en 72 qui
s'appelait simone elle avait 6 ans elle
faisait du vélo et un automobiliste est
arrivé et l'a renversé il a tué alors
qu'il se trouve que le papa de cette
fille était un journaliste très connu
vicquelin nov il a été bouleversé par ce
drame il a dit moi j'ai perdu ma fille
je ne vais pas la récupérer mais je ne
veux pas que ça arrive à d'autres
enfants n'y a d'autre part ans et donc
je vais agir je vais lancer un appel à
tous les néerlandais pour savoir qui
veut m'aider à rendre les routes plus
sûres et à rendre le pays cyclable alors
devinez quoi et des milliers de gens qui
ont répondu c'est devenu un mouvement
national et cet appel fait savez la
forme d'un article qu'il a publiée dans
le journal avec le titre stop au meurtre
des enfants très brut voilà comme sur
ceux cette banderole stop des canards
morte ça fonctionnait et s'était même
les enfants eux mêmes qui sont allés
cette même année voir le président du
parlement néerlandais pour lui soumettre
leurs propositions pour une société
cyclables mais cette pression citoyenne
n'a pas suffi il a fallu un coup de
pouce pour lancer la grande
transformation des pays bas et ça a été
le choc pétrolier en 73 c'est mon année
de naissance donc c'est intéressant tout
d'un coup il m'a plu deux il n'y a plus
de pétrole et donc c'est un problème
parce que toutes les voitures étaient à
l'arrêt et donc le gouvernement des pays
bas qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il a fait il
a organisé les dimanches sans voiture
pour rationné le peu de carburant qui
étaient disponibles et que faisait le
néerlandais bas ils allaient sur
l'autoroute pour faire des patins à
roulettes pour faire du vélo pour jouer
aux échecs pour pique [ __ ] et ils se
sont souvenus alors que tout cet espace
public gigantesque pouvait servir à
autre chose que l'automobile exactement
comme nous en 2020 pendant le
confinement n'est ce pas on s'est rendu
compte à quel point c'était agréable
d'avoir un espace apaisé sans danger
sans bruit sans vitesse
voilà c'est et c'est cette double
pression cette pression des citoyens qui
voulaient une ville de qualité et
cyclables et ce problème énergétique à
cette pression sur un pays qui n'avait
pas le pétrole est toujours pas bien que
les néerlandais ont le gouvernement a
dit on va lancer la transformation vélo
on adopte un plan vélo national
alors je suis sûr qu'à ce moment de mon
histoire il ya au moins une personne
peut être même deux qui pensent que oui
mais je fais comment quand il pleut
et je suis désolé mais les pays bas
c'est plat comme une crêpe mais le
français il ya des collines à ce que je
sache
alors moi je vais je vais vous révéler
un secret ce ne sont pas les vrais
raisons pour lesquelles ne vous le
faites pas tous du vélo parce que la
vraie raison je vous l'a révélé c'est
qu'il manque un réseau cyclable c'est
qu'ils manquent réseau cyclable et le
problème c'est que quand il manque
quelque chose vous ne le voyez pas et
pour le voir il faut faire un effort
d'imagination et c'est pas naturel parce
que peut-être que vous êtes comme moi
vous n'êtes pas urbanistes vous n'avez
pas l'habitude de ré-imaginer l'espace
public tous les jours et donc c'est pas
naturel
je vous donne un exemple regarder cette
rue tout à fait normale n'est ce pas
pourtant cette rue qui n'est pas normal
du tout parce qu'on ne peut pas y faire
du vélo en sécurité parce qu'il n'y a
pas de piste cyclable mais la ville l'a
imaginé et la mise en place tard tout
d'un coup on peut faire du vélo en
sécurité même un enfant on peut faire de
la voiture et on peut marcher
une autre rue tout à fait normale n'est
ce pas moi je crois que si vous trouvez
que cette même comme moi que sept russes
et une rue tout à fait normal c'est
parce que ici dans cette salle nous
avons tous quelque chose en commun nous
avons grandi dans un monde où la
peinture avait déjà pris toute la place
l'espace public mais aussi l'espace
mental et c'est très difficile dans un
monde où la voiture est omniprésent
d'imaginer un monde différent dit on
peut pas
c'est très très compliqué parce que les
personnes qui ont vécu la société
apaisée où il y avait moins de voitures
où on pouvait faire du violon sécurité
eh bien ils sont morts ils ont disparu
avec cette société mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que si vous voulez
recréer cette société cyclable à la
sauce 2021 à la sauce roubaix vous
pouvez il suffit d'être nombreux d'être
organisée et d'avoir un projet
je suis sûr que si vous le dites à votre
mère ou à vos concitoyens ils vont vous
répondre oui mais on ne peut pas parce
que c'est dangereux le vélo alors
regardez cette cette image les personnes
qui portent un casque aux pays bas vous
savez pourquoi parce que les néerlandais
l'ont décidé de protéger les cyclistes
non pas en les casques en mai en cascade
pour leur donner des pistes cyclables
pour qu'il n'ait pas besoin de porter un
casque pour qu'ils soient protégés
voilà c'est aussi simple et tout ça
et c'est pas tout parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui vont vous dire oui mais je
suis désolé on veut bien mais c'est
impossible parce que si on va prendre de
la place à la voiture ça va créer des
bouchons
allez amsterdam vous allez voir le rake
ce musée c'est le musée national qui est
qui dans les années 70 était traversé
par une autoroute urbaine et comme les
habitants d'amsterdam ne savais pas
qu'il était impossible et je dis bien
impossible de remplacer cette autoroute
urbaine par une pelouse et une piste
cyclable parce que soi-disant salek
causé des embouteillages eh bien ils
l'ont fait
vous pouvez il suffit d'être nombreux
d'être organisé la voir un beau projet
maintenant regardons le musée national
français le louvre qui est lui aussi est
traversé par une autoroute urbaine
pensez vous que il est possible de
transformer cette autoroute urbaine par
une gigantesque piste cyclable
mesdames messieurs
c'est à vous de décider il suffit d'être
nombreux
d'être organisée et d'avoir un beau
projet merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]